welcome back to new rock stars i'm eric
voss and this is a breakdown of rick and
morty season five episode six rick and
morty's thanks floytation spectacular an
episode that'll make you feel proud
kinda to be an american by learning
about the truth of thanksgiving aka
national treasure conspiracy theories
turkey dinosaurs
alien vs predator and i guess a bit of
south park at least that's how i learned
it in florida where our textbooks were
menus from jimmy buffett margaritavilles
i'm gonna break down all the easter eggs
animation details
horrible dark secrets that you might
have missed so rick plans to steal the
constitution for the hidden treasure map
on the back like the movie national
treasure when nicholas cage steals the
declaration of independence for its
treasure map
actually in the even worse national
treasure 2 nicolas cage and the
president go to the library of congress
to find the book of secrets containing
details about various conspiracies
including the jfk assassination in area
51 which we know this president rick and
morty also has plenty of knowledge of
the library railings are decorated with
the heads of the eagles america's
national bird
but actually chosen after founding
father benjamin franklin recommended it
to be the turkey which this episode
revises to be our true ancestral avian
overlord rick's rc car knocks over a
bust of thomas jefferson
and nearby is a dueling pistol perhaps
the one aaron burr used to kill
alexander hamilton to make a musical out
of that the car shoots these gelatinous
webs over the security cameras but
not the ones by the vault door
interesting maybe rick didn't care at
that point or maybe it used all of its
fluid to spray the crotches of these
revolutionary army soldiers to make them
look like they wet themselves
not very respectful now the vault door
is marked with in god we trust and its
center appears to just be a large u.s
penny flanking it are busted of george
washington and abraham lincoln
and john trimble's famous 1818 painting
the declaration of independence though
in real life this painting is much
larger
12 feet by 18 feet now the documents in
the case include the constitution's
opening page you can see it's preamble
opening with we the people
and then in congress are the opening
words to the declaration of independence
which is a founding document but not
part of the constitution
declaration of independence side 1776
constitution drafted well
after the revolution but the bill of
rights is to the right of that of course
the first 10 amendments to the
constitution included so that states
rights advocates like james madison
would ratify it but when morty burns a
hole through
these documents the first page of the
constitution actually is untouched
despite
this whole conflict being over morty
destroying the constitution in
particular this laser blasts through the
head of the lincoln memorial the same
way abraham lincoln was shot in the back
of the head by john wilkes booth it
destroys the liberty bell which is
framed exactly how it's on display
outside constitution hall in
philadelphia and then it destroys the
statue of liberty revealing underneath
the trojan horse french assassin robot
they later call her steam-powered and
here you can see she's got a glowing
furnace inside so the military
sieges the smith house you are under
arrest
yes the shimmer the name given to the
similar looking distortion field in the
movie annihilation
jerry whines about the damage being done
to his prostate and the area x in
annihilation emitted some radiation
that i would say was cancerous in nature
i actually think that whole movie is a
metaphor for cancer but when i talk to
friends about it they're like the hell
are you talking about so i might have
been alone in that hey so we all have
some friends we'd like to blow up with a
plasma cannon every once in a while
right well mech
arena is a tactical team based five
versus five shooter game that lets you
do just that jump in blow up mex with
your friends and be out in five minutes
it's got tons of awesome mechs and a
variety of weapons to unlock and upgrade
i like how you can upgrade your mechs
and their weapons don't mind me i'm just
gonna upgrade my autocannon be simple
and effective build a mech to fit your
playstyle with unlimited weapon
combinations and custom skins
my play style right now is don't get
blown up immediately but i'm getting
better there are loads of game modes
like 5 vs 5 death match and solo quick
matches
mech arena is super active with regular
special events in-game competitions and
tournaments with new mechs weapons and
game modes being released every month
mech arena is gearing up for its
official worldwide release in august but
if you're in the u.s canada in the uk
or another lucky country you can get
started right now it's completely free
to play on android and ios
use my link in the description or scan
my qr code and get one mil-spec skin
500 acorns 70 000 credits and get a head
start before
everyone else this is gonna be massive
do not miss out
rick and the president argue you
terrorist you know you use that word so
much it's lost all meaning mr p
it's like at this point what's a
terrorist it's a guy you don't like big
deal you know rick
actually sidestepped a 911 last season
whereas in the season three finale the
two of them rolled past a set in the
white house basement suggesting some 911
conspiracy plot that the white house was
involved with which might be why rick
now says
it might be time to look at the
terrorists in the mirror and
contrastingly the turkey president later
struggles to recall the word terrorist
that these men are what is the word
earth
terrorists now one of rick's defenses is
the carnivorous plant like audrey ii and
little shop of horrors and the president
nods to some superman mythos details
you want a war i'll put your outer space
ass in a goddamn phantom zone with a bar
or kryptonite soap around your neck so
rick plans to trick the president into
giving him a pardon using the loophole
of disguising himself as a pardoned
turkey this is the goofy thanksgiving
tradition with a
long history of turkeys being presented
to the white house since 1873 but
later in this episode you'll notice the
sign in the pen says 1947 referencing
how
president harry truman in 1947 tried to
encourage food rationing of poultry-less
thursdays and found himself getting
bombarded by poultry producers who
presented him turkeys
but truman never officially pardoned any
of them john f kennedy gave an
unofficial turkey pardon in 1963
but the annual tradition of turkey
pardons began in the 80s when ronald
reagan joked that oh he would pardon a
turkey just to deflect questions over
whether he was going to pardon ollie
north for illegally selling guns to
iranians to fund right-wing militias in
nicaragua
and reagan's successor george h.w bush
began the annual pardoning tradition
which we do to this day
and that same president pardoned those
iran contra rascals in his final days in
office
oh america rick and the president brag
about how they've each outsmarted the
other let us not overlook that the
president's first move was to euthanize
the poor turkey handler he snaps at his
vp
careful dwayne you're only vice
president because i need ten percent of
the white vote
not to how presidential candidates will
balance their ticket with running mates
to win over
different groups of voters kind of like
obama with biden in 2008 that 10 percent
he's referring to is probably roughly
the 10
of voters who actually could swing
either way nowadays how things are so
polarized so the marine gets the call
[Music]
coop not on thanksgiving there's not on
thanksgiving they're
in a bar and she's pregnant though she
is drinking water no judgment i'm just
saying it's a bummer place to take her
on thanksgiving especially as rick later
points out
bars actually suck at thanksgiving and
yes his name is coop maybe not to
bradley
cooper as chris kyle an american sniper
but a more prominent reference point
jeremy renner's character in the hurt
locker he wears similar sunglasses a
similar haircut goop is voiced by
timothy olyphant and he asks his wife
baby that little race car driver you got
bacon in your belly what world you want
him rearing up in
one where some spiky-haired doctor who
and a lab coat can change the color of
the sky
doctor who another callback to rick's
words in that season three finale
doctor who and this mother i could be a
clone i could be a hologram
we could be clones controlled by robots
controlled with special headsets that
the real rick and morty are wearing
while they're
your mother actually decoys robots being
controlled remotely
is exactly how rick tries to pull the
president and his forces in this episode
then on to this great country song a
pregnant
girl and a pickup truck by choice in the
[ __ ]
now it's time to turn into a turkey
yeah classic country music themes pickup
trucks accidental pregnancies
shut up it's country and then as the
marines transform it's disgusting and
painful their eyes pop out their skulls
cave in their mouths turn
inside out to form beaks a horribly
painful sacrifice that they have to go
through then they transport to
henderson's turkey farm the turkey farm
more turkeys who might get pardoned by
the president live
and then later the truck reads tommy's
turkey transport proudly transporting
turkeys who might get pardoned by the
president
on top of this truck i love their fight
choreography they jab their heads at
each other and when rick punches one it
releases a gobble
even though they hear each other with
human english speak and the heat of the
moment they start to transform into
their animalistic form meanwhile the
military traps the robot decoys in a
david blaine box
referencing escape artist david blaine
stunt when he spent 44 days in a glass
box in london now inside there's this
weird animation glitch with beth's hand
looks like the animators might have used
an asset file of beth's hand
at that angle to match what it would
look like on her hip but they didn't
blend in the edge at the wrist
the president transforms himself into a
turkey in order to find rick and morty
ship the president has the upper hand
grandpa sunglasses on act like a turkey
now morty and rick are posing as the
marines named rodriguez and fincher
maybe for robert rodriguez and david
fincher
because there is a line here similar to
that line of david fincher's seven
john doe has the upper hand and then
later another venture film gets
referenced i hate every country in the
universe brother they're job placement
programs for the politicians that invent
them
okay fight club the president snaps at
coop it's rick and morty you useless
stump humper sorry don't tell 10 percent
of your friends i called you that
stumphumper of course slang for people
who [ __ ] cows
in florida we elect them to office when
the president attacks him rick worries
about his plume
[ __ ] that's a funny way of showing again
how they're starting to feel more
turkey than human when they're in for
too long meanwhile another soldier
freaks out
270 degrees it's too many to green
yeah turkeys actually do have 270 degree
vision and to show this they switch to a
wider aspect ratio and a bird's eye lens
distortion that stretches out objects on
different parts of the frame so rick
knocks the president's id chip into
another turkey who gets swapped with him
to receive the president's dna backup
when they transform back the flashing
white light silhouetting them evokes the
imagery from
the fly when jeff goldblum reappeared as
a genetic splice of two species
the others are dropped into a feeding
dungeon where they find the only thing
to fear
is me does the white house have a clone
spider of fdr that's no clone it's fdr
he was a guinea pig for the polio
vaccine we ask ourselves what walks the
most
we you're taking credit for this the
office comes with baggage morty
yes franklin d roosevelt suffered from
polio in real life something he hid from
the american public he died in 1945
which led to harry truman becoming
president which in this show's 1947
turkey pardon history might have been
all about keeping this spider fdr fed
now this is yet another bit of dark
baggage that we saw in the season 3
finale that also included the truman
cocaine lounge the kennedy sex tunnels
the mckinley hooker dump the mention of
a lincoln slave coliseum and then that
warehouse containing kennedy's car the
911 set the moon landing set
a set of washington crossing the
delaware and then a floorboard gag a
satanic
seance but fdr being a carnivorous
spider could also be justin roiland
making another shout out to gravity
falls colleague alex hirsch in the
secret history of eight and a half
president and true gravity falls founder
quinton trimbley
the only thing we have to fear is
gigantic
man-eating spiders now notice how rick
actually worked into their turkey
transformation an automatic reversion
timer which if you think about it was
him learning from pickle rick to always
set an expiration so that you don't get
stuck
in this wrong form so they confront the
turkey president in congress
notice how one of the representatives
with the short hair the pearl necklace
she
actually worked with morty when he was a
stock broker in season three's rest in
relaxation
which could just be a little way of
showing how this congress has been
bought out by wall street and is
financially corrupt enough to enact
horrible policy just by giving pay
raises
rick says go go sanchez laser fists
oh [ __ ] i was a turkey for a while
wasn't i yeah not the first time rick
has used this inspector gadget voice
command
go go sanchez ski shoes meanwhile the
president has his own voice command
nicknaming his motorcycle mary todd
lincoln jerry watches a charlie kaufman
reboot of the wizard of oz
that's why i need a brain i'm doing a
terrible job writing this
referring to charlie kaufman movies like
adaptation being john malkovich seneca
new york all
self-deconstructing meta concepts
centering around filmmakers and artists
staging the movies around themselves
meanwhile the news reports
as you can see president curtis has
enacted a plan to turn all turkeys in
america into hybrid super soldiers
i believe this is the first time the
president has been named on the show
he's president curtis
he meets a hostile bartender who still
pissed that jimmy carter left an unpaid
tab of 53 dollars and that guy on tv
isn't me he's a turkey infused with my
dna i'll be
damned well i'm racist
yes the face blindness is real for this
guy too but in this case
with race but if you think about it all
the politicians in washington have this
same problem but whereas they refuse to
admit it this bartender
for better or worse at least recognizes
that he's racist but the president wins
them over with a speech
speeches are words repeated words listed
words
repeated lists of repeated words none of
that matters
you know what does matter me asking you
will you do what i say now actually
keith david first worked with dan harmon
on community in the president's speech
here is a lot like one of jeff winger's
many superficial speeches they delivered
in pretty much every episode and then
was parodied in the season two clip
episode
we've known each other for almost two
years now and yeah in that time
i've given a lot of speeches but they
all have
one thing in common they're all
different so they confront the turkey
forces
sir we've got rick and morty coming in
what appears to be an unlicensed star
wars attack or as the millennials say
1880. so it begins yes yes this debate
comes up a lot on this channel just know
that dave filoni has
intentionally used both pronunciations
along with terms like walker on his
shows
as a way of saying however any fan
describes it they're all right this
turkey commando horribly murders one
soldier by popping his eyeballs out like
blueberries
as they approach the lincoln memorial of
course his head still blown off from
morty's accident earlier they reached
the crypt of the new world and it's
accessed through this
gate covered in masonic imagery
including the masonic square and compass
symbol
and the eye of providence and he says
the treasure you were after is this
country's oldest
secret one disguised by centuries of
thanksgiving folklore
yeah this might be why rick thought he
could try to trick the president in the
sperm monster episode with that whole
spiel about monsters being
rooted in ancient folklore the president
explains how america used to be
dominated by turkeys
is that a turkey dinosaur america's
original rulers merciless
beasts grazing on the flesh of cowering
humans then
in the 15th century a vessel crashed two
vessels really
on board our saviors i remember last
episode rick said that he had just
watched jurassic park on cable and
in that movie there was that scene where
alan grant explains the evolutionary
link between dinosaurs and
birds just have that random kid quip
that doesn't look very
scary more like a six-foot turkey but
these ancient alien saviors appear to be
based on the alien vs predator mythology
the xenomorph versus the yacht-cha the
pilgrim's mouths actually look like the
fangs of the predator and the later
movies in both of these franchises
implied links between
early humans and these advanced races
like prometheus suggested humans were
actually created by these engineers who
also went on to biologically
engineer what became the xenomorphs and
the movie alien vs predator suggested
that the yautja
influenced ancient mesoamerican cultures
later the turkey president blows himself
up with his wishbone similar to the
predator self-destruct function
and one of the alien pilgrims tosses the
president an old musket saying that he
got it from a predator like how in
predator 2 the guy gets tossed a gun
from 1715. but here they awaken both
races of aliens from cryopods and send
them into battle
gentlemen baruch dartin in your day
yeah the language he's speaking here is
actually dothraki from game of thrones
and then these aliens trap the turkeys
in corn stalks
and together they feast on their flesh
just giving a whole new horrible meaning
to all thanksgiving traditions the
turkey president says turkeys sleep in
trees and they fly which is actually
true
turkeys can fly upwards of 50 feet in
the air and they roost in tree branches
rick tells morty to cut the blue wire to
disable the washington monument
they're not exactly primary colors are
we cool with like
turquoise and morty ends up burning the
whole thing as well as the u.s
flag that's on the moon suggesting that
despite the moon landing set in the
white house basement america did
eventually get to the moon i theorized
that rick might have helped them just
one of many things that he has over the
president the turkey president blows
himself up and the president hears his
life echoing past him
the berlin wall has come down it's
called the playstation the winner is
shakespeare in playstation 2. hurricane
katrina slams louisiana playstation 3.
maroon five playstation
four i want a playstation five yeah his
life moments are just limited to the
berlin wall falling 89
shakespeare love winning the oscar 99
rookie katrina maroon 5
cubbies winning the world series and
every generation of playstation what a
life it was the aliens tell the
president
i don't speak guga yeah the president
previously used the word googa
to describe the alien infestation in the
season three finale
some kind of alien googa has infested
the kennedy sex tunnels
and despite the president undercutting
summer's woke take with a crazier
historical truth
morty's takeaway from all this on the
falseness of american exceptionalism
remains the same
i always thought we were more special
than that like we invented everything
and did everything and that's why we own
everything
no i i i don't know what to feel feel
thankful morty
feel thankful leading to this
post-credit scene back with coop
now with his wife and baby shopping for
groceries liked the scene towards the
end of the hurt locker where the guy was
completely overwhelmed by which cereal
to get unable to relate with normal life
and decided ultimately to leave his
family behind again
notice how that blueberry rolls into the
foreground just like that juicy eyeball
snack to that turkey commando and coop
like the turkey life that he can't shake
finds himself trapped in a different
kind of coop of
the poultry variety you know like the
houses they live in
and all while judged by people who just
refuse to pay for his health insurance
heartbreakingly unappreciated happy
thanksgiving
hey you can support new rockstars by
checking out our merch options including
our loki and black widow designs at
newrockstarsmerch.com follow me on
instagram and twitter at eavos follow
and subscribe to new rockstars thanks
for watching bye
[Music]
you